danke Florian Bauer ja sie haben sie
mich schon gesagt was hier in dieser
Woche das große Thema immer wieder war
nämlich im Migration im weitesten Sinne
und wenn man es ein bisschen
runterbricht natürlich die Art und
Weisen wie man damit umgeht mit
verschiedenen geflüchteten oder
Migranten die nach Deutschland kommen
auf der einen Seite heute gleich um 9
Uhr im Bundestag das schon sogenannte
Chancen Aufenthaltsrecht auch
Asylverfahren stehen auf der
Tagesordnung und werden abgestimmt auf
der anderen Seite die Debatte die wir
seit einer guten Woche haben über die
Einbürgerung und eine erleichterte
Einbürgerung da gibt es
interessanterweise bislang nur ein
Papier nur in Anführungszeichen
natürlich aus dem Bundesinnenministerium
aber trotzdem sorgt dieses Papier für
die meisten Diskussionen in diesen Tagen
und deswegen werden wir das an dieser
Stelle auch gleich mal fortsetzen und
umdrehen zu bleiben im Gespräch gestern
ja schon eine Aktuelle Stunde dazu Kevin
Kühnert ist bei uns ja Generalsekretär
der SPD und Mario Chaya der
Generalsekretär der CDU beide sind auch
Bundestagsabgeordnete sonst werden sie
jetzt nicht hier und beide aus Berlin
her Kühnert die Wellen schlagen hoch
habe ich eben schon gesagt warum will
diese Koalition den deutschen Pass wie
beispielsweise Thorsten frei oder
Alexander Dobrindt gesagt haben
verramschen oder wie Mario Czaja sagt
entwerten
ja das wollen wir natürlich nicht und
ich möchte auch gleich noch was zu der
Wortwahl sagen aber vielleicht vorneweg
worum es eigentlich geht wir haben
mittlerweile mehr als 10 Millionen
Menschen in Deutschland die hier
durchaus auch längerfristig leben die
hier arbeiten Steuerzahlen sich in
Vereinen einbringen und andere mehr die
aber nicht über die Staatsbürgerschaft
verfügen manche aus freien Stücken
andere hätten sie aber durchaus sehr
gerne und die eben auch nicht mitwirken
können zum Beispiel in unserer
unmittelbaren Demokratie über die
Willensbildung durch Wahlen die können
wieder gewählt werden noch wählen und
wir sehen es als ein Problem an wenn
gerade in einer modernen
Einwanderungsgesellschaft die
Bevölkerung und das Wahlvolk zahlenmäßig
immer weiter auseinander geht wir hatten
gerade WM oder haben gerade WM in Katar
da Leben zehnmal so als Deutscher hatten
da Leben zehnmal so viele Menschen wie
es tatsächlich Staatsbürger vor Ort gibt
und wir möchten ungerne in einem
Einwanderungsland Deutschland irgendwann
in die Situation kommen das ist eine
kleine Elite von passt deutschen
wahlvorgibt und dann ganz vielen
Fachkräften aus dem Ausland
zwar arbeiten aber nicht mitbestimmen
dürfen es nicht unsere Vorstellung von
Gesellschaft ich habe gerade schon
gesagt gestern aktuelle Stunde hier im
Deutschen Bundestag die habe ich zur
Hälfte verfolgt ich habe aber auch in
diesem Beiträgen nicht verstanden worin
die Entwertung liegt die sie auch
angesprochen haben wir finden die
deutsche Staatsbürgerschaft muss am Ende
einer Integration stehen und nicht am
Anfang wichtig ist dass es Sprachtest
gibt dass man in dieser Gesellschaft
angekommen ist dass man sich zu den
Werten in unserem Land bekennt und ich
habe viele einbürgerungsveranstaltungen
hier in Berlin erleben und ich weiß wie
Menschen sich anstrengen die deutsche
Staatsbürgerschaft zu bekommen Teil
dieser Gesellschaft zu sein und ich
halte es für nicht respektvoll die auch
denjenigen übrigens gegenüber die in der
Vergangenheit viel geleistet haben um
die deutsche Staatsbürgerschaft zu
bekommen dass wir jetzt ein
Schnellverfahren ein fast Ray haben um
in die deutsche Staatsbürgerschaft zu
kommen und das ist die Idee die ja auch
aus der Koalition kritisiert wird die
FDP hat ja auch schon zum Ausdruck
gebracht dass sie das in dieser
Koalition so nicht mitmachen wird für
die deutsche Staatsbürgerschaft braucht
es eben einfach Integrationsleistung und
wenn die gegeben sind dann kann es auch
die deutsche Staatsbürgerschaft geben
und zweitens ist darf nicht einfach so
die doppelte Staatsbürgerschaft geben
sondern wir müssen klar haben wer sich
für das eine Land bekennt oder für das
andere landbekennt muss eben auch das
Feuer zum aus der übrigen bleiben wir
erstmal kurz bei der einfachen
Staatsbürgerschaft nämlich bei der
deutschen bi dann angenommen wird sie
haben ja gerade Ziele definiert sie
sagen das kann am Ende eines
Integrationsprozesses sein wer sagt denn
dass dieser Integrationsprozess fünf
oder acht Jahre dauern muss unbedingt
bzw 8 Jahre dauern muss es ja im Moment
so weil er sagt dass das nicht auch nach
fünf oder drei schon gelingen kann es
gibt heute auch schon unterschiedliche
Regelungen das ist nach fünf nach sechs
Jahren möglich ist dafür sind
Möglichkeiten auch in unserer
Regierungszeit als wir gemeinsam
Verantwortung hatten hier getroffen
worden es liegt aus meiner Sicht nicht
an der Zeit sondern an der Frage wie
hoch ist die Integrationsbereitschaft
und da dürfen wir die Hirten nicht
absenken sondern müssen sie weiter
hochhalten so einfach kann man eben
nicht ein in die deutsche
Staatsbürgerschaft kommen es ist eben
auch das stärkste Aufenthaltsrecht für
einmal die deutsche Staatsbürgerschaft
hat der Meister ein Deutscher und dann
ist es auch bei einer Straftat oder bei
anderen Dingen eben auch einfach nicht
mehr möglich davon abzuweichen Herr
Kühnert senken Sie die
Zugangsvoraussetzungen quasi
hat sie im Prinzip gerade selber schon
rausgearbeitet auch jetzt schon sind die
Regelungen was die zeitliche Spanne die
man hier gewesen sein muss und
Voraussetzung erfüllt haben muss
unterschiedlich gelagert und es
widerspricht sich auch man kann ja nicht
einerseits sagen angeblich stünde jetzt
bald die Einbürgerung am Anfang der
Integration das ist ja nicht der Fall
man muss ja auf jeden Fall erstmal ein
paar Jahre da sein und dann aber sagen
es geht um meine Deutschkenntnisse mehr
zwingend haben das steht drin in dem
Eckpunkte Papier natürlich muss man
Deutschkenntnisse haben aber nicht mehr
nachweisbare Deutschkenntnisse man muss
sich mündlich verständigen können aber
keine deutschsprache über die
Gastarbeiter Generationen an dieser
Stelle an die Menschen über 67 die seit
vielen Jahrzehnten da sind wo wir weil
wir keine Zeitmaschine zur Verfügung
haben nicht mehr die Fehler der 50er
60er Jahre ausmerzen können bei denen
gedacht wurde hier kommen billiger
Arbeitskräfte die bald wieder gehen und
wo man sich nicht entsprechend um
Integrationen bemüht hat das sind aber
Leute die ja seit Jahrzehnten treu zu
diesem Land stehen sie leben hier sie
haben eine große Arbeitsleistung
vollbracht sie haben nächste Generation
in ihren Familien hier ins Leben
hineingeführt und viele von denen
wünschen sich nicht sehnlicher als
häufig am Ende eines langen Lebens doch
noch mal auch ein formales Bekenntnis zu
diesem Land abgeben zu können und das
ist generell das merkt man ja auch in
solchen Beispielen wir kennen die auch
alle das sind sehr emotionale Sachen und
ich finde das einfach nicht angemessen
wie die Union in der Sprache damit
umgeht sie müssen nicht einverstanden
sein mit dem was wir vorliegen das ist
ganz normales demokratisches Prinzip
aber Formulierung wie verschenken oder
sie sagten glaube ich etwas von einer
Black Friday Mentalität oder ähnlichen
das finde ich unerance das ich weiß sie
wollen uns damit treffen aber da gucken
uns Leute zu die sind ganz konkret
gemeint die sehen sich nach dieser
Staatsbürgerschaft und der Möglichkeit
mit zu bestimmen und wenn die sowas
hören dann tut ihnen das glaube ich weh
und ich glaube wir sollten keine Politik
miteinander machen die Menschen weh tun
wir können sofort darauf reagieren
irgendwie müssen sollten Sie auch
unbedingt ich Kevin kühn hat dann an
einer Stelle korrigieren weil sie gerade
gesagt haben die Union es gibt auch
andere Stimmen aus der Union
beispielsweise die nicht ganz
unwichtigen Ministerpräsidenten von
Hessen Boris rein der in Richtung der
Union gesagt hat oder der Fraktion oder
einzelner in der Fraktion jetzt muss ich
selber korrekt sein er Rate zu mehr
Behutsamkeit und Sensibilität in der
Formulierung jetzt dürfen sie auf Gewinn
Kühnheit Antworten
das ist eine Entwertung der deutschen
Staatsbürgerschaft ist wenn
Deutschkenntnisse nicht mehr die
Voraussetzung dafür sind wenn ein
Bekenntnis zu unserer freiheitlichen
demokratischen Grundordnung nicht mehr
Grundlage ist wenn man beispielsweise
bei jungen Müttern die ihr herkommt
automatisch bei den Kindern die hier
geboren wird die deutsche
Staatsbürgerschaft ermöglicht das sind
Rahmenbedingungen die wir bislang in
Deutschland so nicht hatten und ich
finde auch richtig dass wir sie nicht
hatten weil wir haben zwar
unterschiedliche Wege wir haben wir sind
einerseits das eines der Länder mit dem
höchsten Zugang an Asylbewerbern an
Menschen die Zuflucht bei uns suchen wir
sind an dritter Stelle aktuell glaube
ich wenn man den UNHCR Bericht sich
anschaut und haben auf der einen Seite
einen vielen Menschen die wir da nicht
anteilig zur Bevölkerung also da
verschlucken sich jetzt sonst viele
Leute in den Anrainer Staaten zu den
fluchtregionen wir sind das drittgrößte
zufluchtslanden laut Uhren HCR weltweit
und auf der anderen Seite haben wir
fachkräfteeinwanderung und ich finde
erstens wir müssen diese Dinge deutlich
voneinander trennen weil wir ansonsten
auch nicht die Akzeptanz für Humanität
und Ordnung bei der asylzuwanderung in
Deutschland haben werden das passiert
jetzt gerade mit dem sogenannten Chancen
Aufenthaltsgesetz ist und deswegen hier
wenn ihr auch viele Dinge momentan
miteinander vermischt und das zweite ist
dass wir denjenigen die schon da sind
und die die deutsche Staatsbürgerschaft
haben könnten das dafür klar Regeln
gelten und es ist doch kein Geheimnis
die Regeln werden jetzt nach unten
gesetzt das wird jetzt vereinfacht die
deutsche Staatsbürgerschaft zu haben und
aus meiner Sicht ist das eine Entwertung
der deutschen Staatsbürgerschaft auch
bleiben denjenigen gegenüber die eine
hohe Integrationsleistung erbracht haben
ich habe viele in Berlin gesprochen die
bei einbürgerungsveranstaltungen waren
und sagen gelten die Regeln jetzt nicht
mehr die für mich gehalten ich halte das
nicht für gerecht nicht für respektvoll
meine eigenen Leistung gegenüber und
auch meinen Bekenntnis unserer
demokratischen Grundordnung dazu haben
wir wahrscheinlich die Argumente jetzt
ausgetauscht es gibt einen anderen
Kritikpunkt den er mit Scharia eben auch
schon angesprochen hat der kühner
nämlich das verschiedene Bereiche
vermengt werden ich habe ja eingangs
gesagt heute auch geht es um das Chancen
Aufenthaltsrecht es geht um
Asylverfahren auf der anderen Seite
haben wir eben über Einbürgerung
gesprochen und der Vorwurf ist es werde
zu viel miteinander vermengt statt
einzelne die die einzelnen Bereiche
gesondert abzuarbeiten was erwidern sie
dazu
wir sind ja alle intelligente Menschen
und glaube ich in der Lage mehrere
Diskussionen gleichzeitig zu führen
zumindest ist ja unsere Jobbeschreibung
hier in diesem Parlament das sieht man
in jeder Sitzungswoche und deswegen
kommt das ja auch nicht alles in einem
Gesetz daher sondern es laufen halt
Gesetzgebungsverfahren parallel heute
entscheiden wir im Deutschen Bundestag
nachher im namentlicher Abstimmung über
das Chancen Aufenthaltsrecht was hier
schon länger diskutiert worden ist diese
Woche ist im Kabinett eingebracht worden
ein Eckpunktepapier zum Thema Fachkräfte
Einwanderung und dann hat das
Innenministerium das ist das dritte
angesprochene Thema diese Woche von
seiner Seite aus erster Aspekte zur
Veränderung beim
Staatsbürgerschaftsrecht eingebracht das
ist also nicht alles miteinander
vermengt sondern alles wird getrennt
voneinander diskutiert außer man hat
einen Interesse daran ist miteinander zu
verwuscheln und es wird natürlich auch
getrennt abgestimmt am Ende aber klar am
Ende kann man natürlich eine Diskussion
über Migration und das einwanderungs
Deutschland insgesamt führen wir sind
viele Millionen Menschen mit
Migrationshintergrund viele Millionen
ohne deutschen Pass in Deutschland und
vor allem sagt uns die Bundesagentur für
Arbeit seit Jahren dass uns netto jedes
Jahr 400.000 Beschäftigte verloren gehen
wir könnten 7 Millionen Beschäftigte
Arbeitskräftemangel 2035 haben wenn es
so weitergeht und dagegen was zu tun
sollte der Antrieb jeder Regierung sein
die sich vornimmt den
Wirtschaftsstandort Deutschland und
stabilen Arbeitsmarkt zu sichern muss
man Herr Schah ja nicht alle Bereiche
tatsächlich in einem großen Rahmen
zusammen behandeln weil das eine Jahr
unter anderem auch das andere bedingt
und es viele Zusammenhänge ja gibt genau
und deswegen ist der verwunderlich dass
diese Debatten jetzt auch alle zusammen
von der Bundesregierung und
unterschiedlicher Tonalität geführt
werden und eben keine Struktur und
Ordnung hineingebracht wird das wäre ja
eine gute Möglichkeit der
Bundesregierung eben diese unter diese
Unterschiede deutlich zu machen wir sind
ein großes Zuwanderungsland für Menschen
die Asylbegehren das drittgrößte der
Welt wir haben jetzt auch in diesem Jahr
mehr Flüchtlinge aufgenommen als 2015 es
werden auch höchstwahrscheinlich noch in
den kommenden Wochen und Monaten weitere
sowohl aus der Ukraine als auch über
andere Routen und deswegen müssen wir im
Asylrecht sehr klar sein Menschen die
hier asylbedarf haben den müssen wir
Heimat und Zuflucht bieten diejenigen
die ihn nicht haben dann müssen wir auch
von dem Instrument der Abschiebung
Gebrauch machen ansonsten funktioniert
der gesellschaftliche Zusammenhalt im
Land nicht mehr und zu meinen dass
daraus jetzt die große Gruppe der
Fachkräfte kommt entspricht einfach
nicht der Realität wir wissen das von
den Menschen die aus Syrien gekommen
sind weit mehr als 50% heute noch im
Hartz 4 Bezug sind und keine Arbeit
haben das stimmt einfach nicht der
Fachkräfte Zuwanderung diese in
Deutschland im Wesentlichen gegeben hat
in den letzten Jahren ist europäische
Binnenmigration gewesen im Großen und
Ganzen und diese europäische bin
Migration hat während der Pandemie nicht
mehr funktioniert und reicht auch vorne
und hinten nicht sein und muss
qualitativ weiter und der Sektion aber
wir müssen bei der fachkräftezuwanderung
unsere Interessen definieren und bei der
anderen Frage Humanität und Ordnung da
definieren die anderen die Interessen
nämlich ihr Interesse Schutz zu haben
und wenn wir das miteinander vermischen
und das ist genau das was mit dem so
Chancen Aufenthaltsrecht passiert wo
ausreisepflichtige zumeist junge
Menschen bis 27 Jahren zu 75 Prozent
sind es junge Alleinreisende Flüchtlinge
ohne Deutschkenntnisse die bei ihrer
Identitätsfeststellung nicht mitgeholfen
haben dass man denen jetzt sagt Schwamm
drüber ist nicht so schlimm ihr könnt
trotzdem hier bleiben das hatte ich für
falsch und die Akzeptanz für unsere
Asylrecht wird damit nicht steigen
sondern schon zu erwidern die Vorwürfe
sind dieses Chancen Aufenthaltsrecht
fühlt dass Asylrecht aus bevorzugt eine
bestimmte Gruppe zu Unrecht sowas
teilweise auch in der Anhörung im
Bundestag zu hören was sagen sie auch
hier um die Zahlen klar zu haben wir
reden über eine Gruppe von weniger als
eine halbe Million Menschen in
Deutschland die Menschen mit einem
dauerhaften du oder längeren
duldungsstatus bei denen aus
unterschiedlichen Menschen ja und sie
wissen ja auch ganz genau warum es auch
häufig Gründe gibt dass vollziehbare
ausreisen am Ende dann doch nicht
vollzogen werden weil z.B weiterhin
Kriegsgebiete sind aus denen die
Menschen ursprünglich kommen wo sich das
zum Teil seit vielen Jahren nicht
geändert hat und die Annahme unplausibel
ist dass sich sehr bald etwas daran
ändern wird und dann muss man sich als
Gesellschaft irgendwann Fragen erhalten
wir die Fiktion einer baldigen Ausreise
aufrecht in dem Wissen dass die Kriege
in den Herkunftsländern meist nicht
schnell enden werden oder investieren
wir lieber Kraft und Mühe da rein den
Leuten dann auch wenn formal die
Gegebenheiten nicht da waren in einen
Aufenthalt hier zu gewährleisten
entschuldigung aber Sie wollen die ganze
Zeit über das Chancen auftrittsrecht
sprechen das ist auch sehr interessant
aber wir haben schon gewünscht dass sie
mal was zum zum Fachkräfte Einwanderung
sagen weil da liegt ja das deutlich
größere einen gemeinsam
mit einbringen dass ihre Fraktion ja da
gar nicht so komplett geschlossen ist
wie sie gerade in den Eindruck erweckt
haben es gibt mehr als 20 die sagen im
Prinzip ist das was die Koalition hat
gar nicht so eine schlechte Idee war wie
die Menschen ja sowieso nicht
wegschicken können in Kriegs oder
Krisengebiete aber der Zeitraum über den
Zeit über das Zeitfenster müsste man
noch mal nachdenken aber generell haben
mehr als 20 gesagt finden Sie es im
Grunde in Ordnung was haben sie nicht
gesagt wir haben in einer Fraktion über
dieses Thema diskutiert nein das haben
sie mit Sicherheit nicht gesagt 197
Abgeordnete kein einziger stimmt dem
Chancen Aufenthaltsgesetz zu kein
einziger aber mehr als 20 enthalten sich
weil sie sagen
eine geringe Anzahl anschließen wir
haben eine geringe Anzahl an Menschen
die der in der Fraktion an Kolleginnen
und Kollegen die der Auffassung sind
dass man sich zu diesem Gesetz wegen ein
paar wenigen Punkten enthalten kann ich
halte das nicht für richtig die Mehrheit
der Fraktion und der Partei hält das
auch nicht für richtig aber das ist das
freie Mandat das können sie so machen
zustimmen tut ihm keiner was haben sie
gesagt und das zweite ist wir haben
Problem es ist 9 Uhr wir haben im
Hintergrund gehört und ich sehe auf
einem Monitor hier bei mir genau
gegenüber dass die Bundestagspräsidentin
schon angekommen ist und die Sitzung
eröffnet deswegen müssen wir leider an
dieser Stelle auch wenn ich würde mich
freuen wenn wir das bei Gelegenheit
Bilder fortsetzen können ist ja genug
Stoff noch da und noch Argumente sind
auch noch da und alles was ich noch
hätte fragen können unglaublich danke
ihnen beiden ich gebe ganz schnell rein